this is how all rugby players dream of
starting their careers
[Applause]
Harry Morgan was living the dream at the
Ospreys from his teens but with a hidden
growing anguish few athletes talk about
I always find Rugby as my Escape
um mental Escape I was always able to
take my frustrations from day-to-day
life and frustrations of losing my
grandparents at a young age who were
massive influence on me
um those frustrations I always took out
on the Rugby field
um for losing that ability to be able to
play through injury
then took away my Escape what are those
thoughts that are sort of going through
your mind at this point
the factory I couldn't do my job and I
felt as if I was letting my coaches down
letting my players down letting my club
down and letting all my family and
friends down
stress and suffering built up inside the
scrum half who was already scoring
points for Wales in the Six Nations for
the under-20s
the focus was on physical not mental
recovery thoughts come of
what's my point in life what is my
purpose I had no purpose whereas rugby
is always been my purpose I'd lost the
ability to play rugby
so I'd lost a purpose that's when the
suicidal sort of
thoughts and plan and stuff sort of came
into action after Christmas time then
February it obviously came
to a head where I tried taking my own
life and I don't want to be in this
position again I'm to sit in the
hospital with my parents talking doctors
about a way of denim and stuff and
seeing my parents upset
I don't want to be that person anymore
it led to Morgan at 23 taking the
difficult decision this week to step
back from playing the sporty loves
speaking publicly for the first time
about his darkest moments to show
speaking helps to show there's no shame
to show it does get better I think it's
just take every day as it comes is try
and be positive about everything if
something negative happens is try and
look for a positive within that negative
and flip it on his head so we're not
constantly thinking negative
returning to playing rugby in the future
is a possibility but for now mental
well-being is the priority and Harry
Morgan's mission is ensuring no other
rugby player no other person suffers in
silence
Rob Harris Sky News clandassi in South
Wales
foreign